cet événement culturel phare de cet été
partir en livre revient pour une
nouvelle édition à saint quentin en
yvelines pendant un mois cette fête du
livre est organisé par le réseau des
médiathèques de l'agglomération sediag
et son goût bonsoir bonsoir vous allez
nous expliquer cet événement oui du 30
juin au 29 juillet partir en livre
revient pour une septième édition
l'événement s'inscrit dans un dispositif
national dont le principe est de sortir
des médiathèques et de proposer des
animations autour du livre et de la
lecture
la lecture peut paraître quelque peu
rébarbative le mot lecture et quand même
associé à l'école donc la cea quand on
peut il n'y a pas que la lecture
sérieuse apprentissage fit la lecture
ludique
l'idée c'est de proposer un maximum
d'activités autour de de la créativité
l'imagination
quel sera donc le programme à 50 ans
divine célia alors il y aura de
nombreuses activités et des ateliers
tout au long du mois à villepreux magny
les hameaux guyancourt maurepas ou
encore plaisir
activités manuelles dessin manga contes
expositions exposition il en aura pour
tous les goûts avec un temps fort à la
commanderie à elancourt les vendredi 9
et samedi 10 juillet de 10 heures à 18
heures
le réseau des médiathèques en
partenariat avec la commanderie investi
tout où les tous les espaces de la
commanderie avec une proposition de
village littéraire avec un espace
lecture des expositions des concerts des
lectures des jeux des ateliers manuels
d'illustration autres dates samedi 17
juillet à la médiathèque jacques-prévert
et aux quartiers du village des
clayes-sous-bois en après-midi sous le
signe de la magie avec des quizz pour
tester vos connaissances sur les mondes
fantastiques les histoires qui enchante
ou encore la création d'un carnet de
voyage et à maurepas tous les jeudis du
mois
des lectures et des comptes en plein air
seront proposées à l'air de jeu de
cartes le pirate est donc laquelle
sanitaires on va quand même permis de
faire évoluer les pratiques puisqu'il y
aura aussi une programmation en ligne
oui sur le portail des immédiat tech de
saint quentin en yvelines
vous pourrez retrouver de nombreux
contenus présents
à sion du compteur ludovic souliman vous
pouvez retrouver aussi une proposition
d'activités autour de la comptine de la
souris verte qu'on peut chambouler
donc c'est une petite activité
d'écriture pouvait aussi trouver une
sélection de livres de lecture autour de
la métamorphose
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
retrouver le programme en intégralité en
livre de partir en livre également sur
le portail en ligne des médiatiques
merci c'est d'agathe son goût d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir